now you can see all my groins here and
you'll need these drawings too if you
haven't already go ahead and draw these
ones underneath because we're gonna talk
about something really important in
connection to these we have been looking
at calculus right calculus is the
mathematics of things that change and
one of those important things that we
can measure in terms of change is motion
how things move through space and in
fact really this is kind of this overlap
between mathematics and physics they
aren't the same thing but physics is
mostly about objects that move right and
master a material and all that kind of
thing so you can see here we've got our
our man's that got shot up in his cannon
came back down and then is what was this
point here what did that represent the
parachute thank you very much we had a
bumper cars it was sort of traveling
along and then something happened what
happened it's very morbid of you he may
have died in the collision but he
crashed is the most important thing so
he stopped and then lastly what was this
one out isn't that the ferris wheel it's
going up and down okay so we're gonna go
through each in turn but the important
thing I want you to get across as we
first look at these is what were we
actually measuring in each case the
first and the last ones were the same
what was the thing that asks you to
graph think carefully
look remember right what was he actually
doing it was actually the height from
the ground right this is the height from
the ground so if we were to mark in and
I would like actually to all do this if
we're a marking here our vertical axis
we should call this guy what that's
what's actually being measured we would
normally put like aa vertical axis is
why we often do that but in this case we
actually have a thing we're moving in
vertical space that's why we'd call it
high and it's the same for the last one
as well with the ferris wheel now what
was the horizontal axis what was going
on there we're measuring time thank you
very much now hopefully this hearkens
you back and this is the same for all
three
hopefully this hearkens you backed to
over thinking that you say bolt and he
was running right now this is the
crucially important part that I want you
to see for all of them and we'll connect
it all together for all of these what
we're measuring is mark this place what
we're measuring is a
one dimensional quantity let me say that
again we're measuring a one dimensional
quantity height it just gets up like
higher and lower right this height here
the ferris wheel we're just measuring it
up and down we don't care about where
this thing is moving horizontally cannon
man is not moving horizontally at all
he's just going up and then down so
we're using a two dimensional space but
the thing we're measuring in terms of
distance the motion is just one
dimensional up and down okay it's just
on a straight line right so it's really
important that we get this horizontal
theme is time now as we were then
looking at it right we noticed some
things like say for example these
important points I've got a couple here
and here that we could know in what did
they represent like say this first one
up here oh we call this we have a name
for this right yeah we call this a
stationary point and motion is actually
the context that makes the most sense of
this because at that instant in time
cannon man is doing what he's being
stationary he's not moving not going up
not going down he's just at the at the
apex of his motion okay he heads up he
comes back down because of the force of
gravity but I want you to notice see
this part here right do you notice it's
curved the steepness changes as you go
along why is that yeah go it accelerates
why is he accelerating yeah gravity yeah
this is actually really interesting
right if you have another color there's
to be handy you said to me Oh gravity is
pulling him down right is gravity not
pulling him down at this point
interesting so the physics people like
ah ha I know what's going on here right
gravity is always acting here gravity is
always acting but there are other forces
involved for starters what happens at
time zero
yeah yeah he's yes he is he is about to
be and consequently launched out of the
Canon sir there's a force acting on him
but that force doesn't keep on acting
does it the canons gone and so gravity
is kind of acting all the way here right
it's his displacement which is changing
okay
what's this critical point here what
happens an event happens the parachute
right so when the parachute comes out
what effect does that have on his
mushroom
yeah it's now this is really sneaky
right because his motion his descent it
slows down right but I'm going to and we
sort of need to be very careful language
here I'm gonna steer clear from using
the word decelerate because in a sense
it's just a different kind of
acceleration right it's fixed
acceleration in a different direction
because there's a parachute right
it's accelerate but with a DNN II
instead of an a in a C but I'm still not
going to use that word because because
colloquially it means something quite
different to technically so I'm not
going to talk about it
in that terms but you can see still
descending but this time what did you
draw here what did you draw in the
second yeah very good
or all the words right so this straight
line here right represents his
trajectory he's not speeding up he's not
slowing down the pouch is just kind of
letting him down gently which is a good
thing because if it didn't happen what
would the graph look like without the
parachute what would you guess yeah he's
just gonna he's just gonna hit the
ground and that's gonna be pretty nasty
right or he's gonna break his leg
that'll be not fun okay now this is very
important what we've got up here is a
graph of displacement in this case
vertical displacement which we would
call height versus time but underneath
this I want us to draw a new graph and
I'll give you a minute or two for this
instead of drawing height what I'd like
is to draw is his speed speed okay how
fast is he going at any given time now I
say speed very deliberately because
speed is just about how fast you're
going
not we
direction you're going in will come to a
little bit later you can see I'm leaving
that to the end so I'm just about is he
going fast or is he going slow and if so
how much okay so I'm gonna let you have
a go a drawing that see what you get
speed just how fast he's going
don't worry about whether he's going up
or down just tell me is he going fast is
he going slow and represent that on the
graph and it's still time on the
horizontal axis give you a minute see
what you can come up with